let's say we're told that the position
of a particle can be figured out from or
the or the position the position of a
particle as a function of time is given
by this crazy expression the position
could be positive or negative and this
expression is t minus a times a minus t
times t minus a times t minus b all of
that over the square root of a squared
plus b squared and they also tell us
that c is greater than b is greater than
a is greater than zero
so given that information we have two
statements right over here we have the
position at time c on the left hand side
and over here we have the number of
times that our function is equal to zero
the number of times that p of t is equal
to zero what i want you to do is pause
the video right now and think about
which of these statements provides a
larger value is p of c
greater than or less than than the
number of times p of t equals 0 and i
guess a third and fourth option would be
that you maybe don't have enough
information to figure this out or maybe
that these are equal so i encourage you
to figure that out right now which of
these are larger or do you not have
enough information or are they equal
so i'm assuming you've got given a go at
it so let's think about each of them so
let's think about what p of c is
so p of c is going to be equal to right
here p
i'm i don't want to arbitrarily switch
colors which i sometimes do p of c
p
of c
is going to be equal to let's see it's
going to be c minus a i'll just solve
this one color
i'll do it it's going to be c
minus a times a minus c
times c
minus a
minus b
all of that over
all that over the square root of a
squared plus b squared
so what do we know about this quantity
what do we know about this quantity
right over here let me highlight all the
c's here so c minus a
a minus c c minus a c minus b
well they tell us that c is larger than
a and b and that they're all positive so
maybe we can come up with some statement
about whether this thing is positive or
negative what whether this expression is
so what's c minus a going to be
well c is greater than a so this is
going to be positive
what about a minus c
well a is less than c so this is going
to result in a negative number
c minus a well this is going to be a
positive again and then c minus b is
also going to be a positive c is greater
than both b
and a
and what do we have here in the
denominator well the square root of a
squared plus b squared well that's this
is just going to be this is going to be
a positive value
so what do we have going on here here in
the numerator i have a positive times a
negative times a positive times a
positive so what's that going to be
well that's going to be a negative a
positive times a positive times a
positive is positive and then you throw
that negative in there so you're going
to get you're going to have a negative
over
a positive and what's a negative divided
by a positive well that's going to be
a negative
so we don't know what the actual value
is but all we do know is that this
provides us with a negative
a negative value
so if this ends up being a positive
value then we can make a statement if
this we just say hey this is a negative
value as well then we might not have
enough information so let's think about
the number of times p of t is equal to
zero
well p of t is equal to zero whenever
the numerator right over here is equal
to zero and when would the numerator
equal zero well i have the product i
have the product of this one two three
four
four expressions so if any one of these
expressions is zero then the entire
numerator is going to be zero so let's
think about how you can make these
expressions zero so the expression could
be zero this will be zero if t is equal
to a
this would also be 0 if t is equal to a
and this would also be 0 if t is equal
to a and this would be 0 if t is equal
to b
so there's two values that would make
two values for t that will make this
numerator equal zero t equals a or t
equals b so there's two times so the
number of times that p of t is equal to
zero is
is two
so now let's answer our question what is
larger the number two the number
positive two versus some some negative
number well two is larger than any
negative number so this
this
is the larger quantity